you
[Music]
all right hello everyone my name is
Colin I have the foolish ambition of
trying to get through two projects in
ten minutes right after lunch so
hopefully this will wake you all up the
first project is what we call project
Katia cardio means work in Hindi and the
goal of Project Katia is to provide
dignified digital labor I think most of
you and the audience probably know about
this notion of crowdsourcing so the
basic idea behind crowdsourcing is that
we're going to take a large scale
digital task
preferably digital tasks that are hard
for computers to automate and we're
going to chop this task into millions of
little pieces what we call Micro Micro
work then we're going to give this micro
work to humans to people to accomplish
and then we're going to collect the
results at the end that's the basic idea
now what's unique about project Korea is
the demographic of workers that we're
targeting
so the typical crowdsourcing worker
today is college-educated feels
relatively comfortable with spoken and
written English and often has access to
a laptop or a desktop computer now the
population that we're targeting here are
rural Indians typically low-income
people who may not have any of those
three traits that I mentioned so our
goal with project kardia is to improvise
employment opportunities for these
people and as much as that we're also
trying to help them build a set of
digital skills IT skills for example so
that they can build a resume over time
and hopefully get to get a job of their
own once they're done with our project
and all the while of course we're trying
to accomplish useful tasks and collect
useful data so you can think of project
cardia as much as a social welfare
program as it is a crowdsourcing
platform in fact in the long term we're
hoping to partner with the Indian
government to help scale this up as a
social welfare program the technology we
have is a here we have a server that
takes in some tasks like a pile of
and written forms and then chops that
task into individual pieces of micro
work like pictures of individual words
in that form and then hands it out to an
Android application that used that that
workers can use to accomplish those
tasks gain skills earned money etc and
then we collect all of the results at
the end the range of tasks that we're
targeting is fairly broad we're looking
at image classification form
digitization translation even tasks like
geo tagging so going out with your phone
and taking pictures of things or even
taking sensor measurements maybe taking
soil measurements in rural areas
we've been working in earnest on this
project for about six months there is a
beautiful photo of Rover maharashtra
that manu chopra took manu is kind of
leading this project so far we've done
one initial user study in partnership
with iit bombay and we're dealing with a
auto basi community in rural maharaja
felt like i mentioned most of the users
here actually they have never actually
used a smartphone before so the task
that we gave them was actually fairly
straightforward which is on the
smartphone use a Marathi keyboard to
enter their name and the results were
pretty promising there's a there was a
nice picture you can see our first user
of project katya so there's a lot of
things that we've learned in the last
six months both in talking to government
agencies and doing these user studies
i'm just going to focus on one of the
challenges that we've encountered which
is a very basic problem these people do
not make very much money they cannot
afford very much cellular data so even
if there are NGOs or public service
announcers or even for-profit content
providers that want to give content for
free to these people they can't do so
because the users have to pay for the
data they can't afford the data to
download in the first place so that
brings me to my next set of slides right
the next project we call people power
data and networking
both data networking there have been a
lot a lot of project proposals in the
past for how to get internet to the rest
of the world SpaceX is thinking about
low-earth orbit satellites Facebook is
thinking about these big drones Google
was thinking about these
and what most of these projects don't
really understand is how people already
make use of the Internet today in a
place like rural Bihar what they what
these companies like Google and Facebook
are not realizing is that people have
already figured out how to get their
hands on Internet content even if they
can't afford the internet access namely
there are these apps that people use to
transfer files between phones so one of
the phones turns on a hotspot the other
phone connects to the hotspot you can
transfer files at very fast rates okay
so this is really popular this is really
this is actually all over the world not
just India one of the most popular of
these apps is called Sherratt they claim
to have 200 million users in India alone
so this is a massive thing and before
that before smartphones there was of
course Bluetooth people have been doing
this for a long time now the way that
this is done today is unfortunately
still quite limited it's quite ad hoc
and one of the biggest limitations is
that I typically only share with people
that I know so I have to go and talk to
you and say do you have this movie that
I want to do I have this file should we
share I can't share with people like you
in this room we're within Wi-Fi range we
could be transferring files right now
but I don't have any content discovery
mechanism so the basic research question
we're asking here is if we provide some
services like content discovery
can we change people's behavior can we
enable people to start sharing that
helped between people who have never met
each other let's start sharing this room
because we started out we have files
that other people want so what we have
is is pretty straightforward we just
have some like cloud service that runs
say you know in a South Indian data
center and a content provider like I
don't know some NGO has some video that
they want to distribute to people they
give us a copy of that file and we
extract some metadata from that file and
then we run an Android app on on
people's smartphones and this Android
app automatically detects if I have some
of the files that the content providers
have given us without actually having to
download over solid
just using metadata like a cache of the
content and the other thing this app
does is it automatically detects if I'm
within range within Wi-Fi range about 80
meters of someone else who has a file
that I want or vice versa it will
automatically turn on on the Wi-Fi and
automatically perform that transfer now
one other cool feature is that if the
NGO or the content provider wants to
incentivize people to spread this kind
of in a viral way they might even be
willing to give money I'm not going to
be able to draw a rupee symbol excuse me
I'll draw a dollar sign instead so if if
they want to incentivize someone to
spread this virally the person who has
the content that's spreading it to the
other person they will receive a mobile
top-up this is like a form of cellular
data basically so the idea here is that
we can make this spread virally by
having them take the effort to go walk
to the next village and and earn some
mobile tacos by giving it to other
people okay now from the users
perspective this is great on getting
content showing up on my phone for free
I don't even have to touch the phone and
even I might be able to earn mobile tops
just by simply running an app on my
phone this is a really big value
proposition for people in rural India
and from the content providers
perspective I think this is what's
perhaps most exciting they have a way of
reaching a population which they didn't
have a way to reach before and another
nice advantage is they can track how
many times is this file being watched
how many times is it being transferred
and this enables opportunities like
advertising which is important for
someone like an NGO and then the last
opportunity like I mentioned is if
they're if they're willing to put in a
little bit of money to for mobile
top-ups they can cause viral spread of
some of these some of this content that
they want to distribute so that's
actually all I was going to say I'm
really excited for the panel discussion
at the end thank you very much